so far in this series relative to
medicinal pseudoscience you know the
kind that actually kills people yeah
that one I've covered hydrogen peroxide
therapy and black salve which are pretty
high in the quackery scale but in my
opinion magnet therapy takes the cake
for being the craziest idea and I've
seen some crazy I'm talking about you
Jillian Eppley at least with these
there's an internal medicinal aspect
that sort of makes sense to a naive
person because you're treating them like
they're actual medicine either ingesting
it or using it as an ointment hmm
maybe I should use this black salve to
treat my pinkeye well guess I'm blind
now but using a magnet to heal your body
no magnet therapy is one of the oldest
recorded medical treatments in history
dating back as early as 4000 BC and
China and if there's anything that's
true about ancient medicine it said it
has no scientific grounding whatsoever
okay so you're telling me if I bleed out
a liter of blood it'll cure my syphilis
brilliant just a quick side note magnet
therapy is not to be confused with
transcranial magnetic stimulation which
is a real medical treatment that's used
by neurologists to treat depression and
other neurological ailments the
application of magnet therapy today
hasn't really changed since ancient
times you had here a static magnet to
location on your body either as a
bracelet a ring the brace shoe insert or
under your mattress weight an arbitrary
amount of time and you get two
treatments two of the most commonly
cited benefits of magnet therapy are
pain reduction and improving blood flow
which are of course wrong firstly pain
reduction one problem with this is
studies that try to show a correlation
between pain relief and magnetism are
consistently inconclusive if a medical
treatment is effective under the same
conditions it would show consistent
results this is how treatments are
discovered and approved through
stringent repetitive testing you
wouldn't want a surgeon who performed
inconsistently on the last dozen
surgeries right you want someone who
does good consistent work in a
systematic review by the Canadian
Medical Association Journal 29 clinical
trials that tested whether static
magnets had any effect on pain reduction
were reviewed the analysis found there
was no evidence to support any
conclusions that magnetism relieve pain
enhanced blood flow is often referenced
as a benefit of magnet therapy the
obvious reason is that iron is in
hemoglobin and iron is magnetic firstly
ironed in your red blood cells is not
magnetic like elemental iron is meaning
it doesn't form a permanent magnetic
field or have a strong attraction to a
magnet elements that are ferromagnetic
such as iron nickel and cobalt all have
their own magnetic fields due to the
arrangement of electrons within the atom
in the presence of a magnetic field the
electrons are oriented differently and
become attracted to the field
this makes ferromagnets very strong and
in fact able to retain their own
magnetism iron in hemoglobin in red
blood cells is not ferromagnetic but as
either paramagnetic or diamagnetic para
magnetism is when something is very
weakly magnetic and requires a very
strong magnetic field to produce even a
mild attraction stronger stronger
perfect examples are lithium oxygen
potassium titanium and magnesium just
name a few if something is diamagnetic
then it completely repels the magnetic
field there is no attraction whatsoever
examples are silver or gold which is why
they're used in jewelry quick summary
magnetism is based on the arrangement of
electrons in the atom ferromagnetic
elements have very strong electron
Arrangements paramagnetic have weak ones
and diamagnetic have opposite
arrangements to the magnetic field all
right we good moving on
wait wait wait how can iron in your
blood be in two different magnetic
states well because the iron atom in
hemoglobin changes electron arrangements
when it binds to oxygen thereby changing
the magnetic properties of the iron this
is because the job of hemoglobin is to
bind and transport oxygen throughout the
body which it does quite well when
oxygen binds to iron the iron atom has a
charge of plus three changing its
electron structure to a diamagnetic
state when the iron is not bound oxygen
its electron structure is at a plus two
charge making it paramagnetic yes the
iron in hemoglobin is technically
magnetic but hear me out it's very very
weak it's so weak that's who observe
even a slight attraction would require
an industrial-sized magnet like the kind
inside an MRI machine and even then the
attraction is barely noticeable in fact
the attraction is so weak that an
average static magnet even a neodymium
magnet our magnitudes too low to exploit
any attraction yeah but what about a
really really powerful magnet well the
goths rating of a typical static magnet
used for therapy is between eight
hundred and twelve thousand Gauss
while Magnus use an MRI scan
run between 20,000 and 70,000 Goths
surprisingly when people go through MRI
scanners there's no effect on their
blood circulation it's almost as if
there's no relation to magnetism and
blood flow hmm but even if you were
relentless and still believed blood is
magnetic because it has iron in it you'd
still be dead wrong the majority of the
blood in your body is diamagnetic and
therefore repels the magnetic field
recall that when iron and hemoglobin
binds to oxygen it becomes diamagnetic
well ninety-six percent of the
hemoglobin in your arterial circulation
and seventy percent in your venous
circulation is bound to oxygen this is
best demonstrated in a video by Brainiac
75 where he repels an entire bucket of
blood using an industrial magnet even if
you did have access to this kind of
magnet you'd only be weakly attracting a
small minority of red blood cells so the
idea that you can alter or redirect red
blood cells with a magnet is a no okay
blood isn't magnetic right but magnetism
must have an effect on blood flow and
why is that because and this scientific
study in 2011 showed magnetism reduced
blood viscosity so how about that are
you [ __ ] this study blood was placed
in a one millimeter capillary tube kept
at 90 degrees Fahrenheit and was moved
past a magnetic field of 1.3 Tesla units
or 13,000 Gauss for one minute as a
result the red blood cells rearranged
from scattered distributions to short
linear chains causing the viscosity to
drop by 20 to 30 percent well boys I
guess magnets affect blood flow after
all that's case closed so who's buying
drinks tonight ya know there is one
small problem with this study it's an in
vitro study the blood was tested outside
the body which is a big deal because it
presents a bunch of different variables
and should be taken with one hell of a
massive grain of salt really this study
should be called the effects of blood in
a magnetic field in a capillary tube
outside the body but it's not and it's
misleading this matters because blood
inside the body versus in a tube are two
very very different things in the body
blood is flowing through different sized
vessels changing flow rate and binding
and releasing oxygen all under layers of
muscle and skin these same variables
aren't occurring in the tube this raises
all kinds of questions is the blood in
closer proximity to the magnetic field
in the tube than it is in the body does
the blood being outside the body changes
properties that would affect the results
of the experiment the tube the blood was
in was one millimeter but blood vessels
range in diameter from 8 micrometers up
to 25 millimeters so does this effect
only happen the blood vessels at 1
millimeter or are all sizes affected
there's a lot of unanswered questions
here and according to the author's
research history there were no further
investigations into these findings
unfortunately for you Pro magnet therapy
people this study provides no evidence
of magnetic fields having any reliable
clinical effect on blood it's merely an
exploratory in vitro study lacking
important biological conditions so yeah
as it stands magnet therapy is still
quackery has no real replicable or
explainable effect on pain reduction
blood flow or energy fields whatsoever
all right boys that's a wrap so who's
buying the round of drinks tonight oh
you guys on the stupid scale I'm reading
magnet therapy at a 7 out of 10 and on
the harmful scale at a 1 out of 10 and
click the bell to subscribe you know
[Music]